my name is Skip mass back and I am
lesson faith and flourishing program at
the Yale center of faith and culture and
this is a collaboration of the Yale
Center for faith and culture Yale
Divinity School the Berkeley Divinity
School and the youth ministry initiative
and what I mostly want to say is thank
you thank you for what you do thank you
for what you do in ministering to youth
and thank you for joining us today our
aspiration across our program I hope
you've got a brochure so you can see the
cool speakers that we've got I mean
we're off to kind of a slow start with
Andy route but we're going to pick it up
we're going to pick it up next month
with chap Clark I promise it's a
wonderful wonderful series of speaker is
it's a free lunch you can't hate that
mostly what I hope we experience
together is an evolution of a community
a community of folks who are passionate
about ministering to our youth you know
this so I'm not telling you something
you don't know it's easy to say youth or
the future of the church what's true is
they are the vital present of the church
and you are the front line folks helping
to form faith amongst these incredible
young people that we're blessed to have
in our churches so a notion of community
I hope we're not all clicked up at
denominational tables we're going to
have to do icebreakers you know how
those go and youth group if you do that
because we have a rich opportunity to
talk to meet to learn from one another
of course the next eight months as we do
this series first Tuesday of every month
I hope that you'll stay in connection
with this if you haven't already join
our facebook page at youth ministry now
check out our what's going to evolve as
a distance learning resource where all
these videos will be posted at ww youth
ministry initiative org and basically
the role of the youth ministry
initiative which is this collaboration
is to support what you're doing to
resource what you're doing to research
and develop deep theological and
scriptural foundations to enrich what
you're doing and to keep us going
because this can be an isolating job but
it shouldn't be we should be gathering
like this more often and taking energy
and strength and just sheer fun from
gathering together
every single second I speak I'm taking
time away from Andy root and he tends to
go on anyway so so I'm going to try to
keep this short I have a couple of
introductions first a great deal of
gratitude to Dean Joe Britain who really
gave us this start by giving us a
footprint and a partnership berkeley
last year Dean thank you Berkeley's
thrilled to be able to participate in
supporting this and welcome everybody
welcome back to many of you the room
were in is the old refectory partially
renovated going to be a swing space for
the Opera and drum program at the music
school while they renovate their space
so I don't think this is the current
state of Yale Divinity School we are far
beyond this just a word of explanation
welcome thank you Joe another part of
the youth ministry initiative will be to
resource and then to drive support for
youth ministry across our various
denominations and I have a
co-conspirator who has already foolishly
signed up for this who's going to help
us coordinate and support youth ministry
throughout the Episcopalian tradition
Michael bird father Michael bird would
you stand up just so people can put a
name together as a face the rector at
bronxville so if you're wearing a collar
you're not a Roman Catholic you'll be
hearing from him or army or Lutheran
you'll be hearing from father Michael
bird we are recruiting if you are from
any of the other traditions we had 14
traditions joining us last year 140
folks from 14 traditions everything from
Roman Catholic nuns and habits to
Buddhist monks and garbs so we have a
diverse group if you would like to help
coordinate for your denomination please
come see me so I'm going to say grace
because I see everybody's eating here
but by the power invested in me and
ordination and laying on of hands i'm
going to do a retroactive grace so let's
pray I gracious God we offer a word of
thanks to you we thank you for your
calling your claim on each of the lives
of the folks of this room to minister to
children who were after all your
children before they were our children
we thank you for this calling and we
thank you for the faithful response of
the folks into this room
we pray that you'll continue to bless
our gatherings we ask you to bless this
food and the hands that prepared it may
our time together be pleasing to you and
generative in the ministry into the
world we asked for this in Jesus name
Amen so I really could go on a great
length about Andy root and he doesn't
want me to because again I'm picking his
pocket for time Andy root is a really
extraordinary generator of intellectual
capital thought leader for youth
ministry throughout the country holds a
chair in youth ministry and family
ministry at luther seminary and st. Paul
you've seen the rest of the biography
I'm not going to go on because I want
them up here really grateful Andy for
you coming east it's yours all right it
is a pleasure to be back here and I'm
just going to jump in and this is a very
kind of it's a great room to see you all
here but I also we're talking about
screens and ironically I have to teach
off a screen so you just keep the irony
going as we go here today but I do want
to talk about living in the screen based
world which seems like if there's one
thing true about the young people that
we are working with is that they live in
a screen based world that they have
their phones or their computer screens
up all the time I actually had a youth
worker who told me not too long ago that
they did a fall retreat in kids were
actually asked to hand in their cell
phones before they made it to the camp
and kids were using dummy cell phones so
that they would hand in a cell phone
that was wasn't working so they could
keep their cell phone and he actually
talked to some of these kids and they
had utter anxiety of giving up their
cell phone and then of course their
parents didn't want them to give him up
either so they could contact them and
text them and things like that but it
seems like we live in this really
significant world where our screen is
everywhere now even though some youth
workers who work in South Africa and
they see one of the most interesting
things as you go into townships
incredibly poor townships and you will
look inside of some of these habitats
these people are living in and there'll
be kids with cell phones with
smartphones watching English Premier
Soccer or something that the screen has
permeated globally and many sense now
it's easy to be critical of that
or to want to push back against that but
I had to admit especially living in
Minneapolis and st. Paul in the middle
of februari and if you've ever been
there in the middle of februari may God
have mercy on your soul it is cold and I
realized one februari a few years back
that my whole world was really framed by
two screens that I spent my whole life
either laying on my living room floor
watching TV or in my office rubbing a
piece of plastic on a table to bounce in
and out of worlds that's my mouse it's
not something dirty it sounds dirty but
that my whole world was framed either by
46 inches that I wish was 60 or 13
inches that my whole world was framed
that way and I started to wonder with
the young people I work with as well as
myself how this changes meaning how is
meaning constructed differently in a
screen based world now one night when I
was actually watching TV my favorite
late-night talk show is Jimmy Kimmel
Live I love Jimmy Kimmel and if you ever
watched Jimmy Kimmel on at least 11
central time that he always has a big
musical artist at the end in this
particular night he had Kanye West
America's favorite narcissist was
actually on his show he had just
released his album he was very
significant at this time and i want to
show you just about 10-15 seconds of
this performance and what i want you to
look at are the young people in the
first five to six rows what do you see
with these young people as you watch
this 15 seconds of this concert
yes
alright so you can you see it pretty
obvious so here are these kids at this
real event the biggest music musical
artist is just a stone's throw away from
them and here they are taking it in
through there 2 inch or 3 inch screen
there at the real event but yet are
choosing to take it in through their
screen so what does this mean that we
are actually mediating reality often and
our young people are through screens
what I want to actually talk about this
afternoon and this is dangerous I want
to talk to you about maybe one of the
preeminent French philosophers on post
post modernity jean baudrillard now I
realize whenever you say a post modern
French philosopher it's like trip to
fans in it it's like after Thanksgiving
you just get super tired like did he
really say this I'm done all right now
the truth is is that all of you have run
into the name most of you I'm sure have
run into the name John bossier here
before if you have ever seen the matrix
which it is let me give you another
point it is really lame to talk about
the matrix and in your ministry so don't
stay the kids like hey remember the
matrix in 1997 wasn't that cool kids
like I wasn't born yet so having said
that now I can talk about it if you if
you remember the matrix and one of
America's great greatest actors Keanu
Reeves is an effort soon and if you
watch piano you know he can only do one
thing whoa that's all Keanu could do so
if you remember kyon O's in this room at
the very beginning of the matrix and
it's this dark damp room and he gets a
knock on the door and he goes to it
looks like there's a drug deal going
down but it isn't actually a drug deal
he actually goes to the safe and pulls
out a book and opens the book and it's
hollowed out and there are some disks in
it or something and he gives these
people two disks the book he takes out
and opens up is John Bowe shares book
simulation and simulacra now the wall
kofsky brothers who wrote this movie
were inspired by baudrillard work and
his cultural critique now bochur had
heard that before he had died he'd read
that and watched the movie and as a good
French philosopher he said this American
movie has drivel my work is so much more
significant than this but it was
inspiring and what blow-dryers basic
point is he thinks it's become hard for
us actually in our cultural context in
Western societies to construct meaning
because we are bombarded by images there
are
images everywhere that we are actually
drowning in images and he makes this
argument that it's actually hard to
construct meaning when we are drowning
by images now why he thinks that is
because he thinks that we make structure
or we make meaning through a structure
and particularly language and the
structure is signed to the thing it
signifies the way we go about making
meaning is signed to the thing it
signifies now this is my daughter see
you people are cruel you're supposed to
say ah come on I thought people on the
East Coast were nice that's what that's
Midwesterners think so this is my
daughter when she was about seven eight
months and we have two dogs don't ask me
why we have two dogs we have a black
Labrador in a golden retriever and the
golden retriever is as dumb as the day
is long but he's loving as can be but my
daughter ever since she was even a
little infant has loved these dogs and
she whenever she would see them she
would Glee with delight well around
seven or eight months she actually
learned the sign for these four-legged
animals that allow her to jump on them
and lick her face and so she would see
them and she would Glee dog dog dog she
learned the sign to signify the real
thing four-legged furry animal and she
started to make meaning with this so we
would take her on a walk and she would
see a dog three or four blocks away and
she would glee and shout dog dog a dog
and so she was constructing meaning now
my wife has a friend and they had their
first born children around the same time
so there forever linked and her friend
lives in atlanta now and she often makes
her like mix CDs and sends it to her
which i think is so cute and so like
1990s you know to make a mixtape and
it's often half the songs are like
children songs and then half are like
old classic rock songs and my wife will
play for my kids and these volumes of
CDs sent by her friend become kind of a
lower in our family well one of the cds
actually had the queen song on it we
will we will rock you you know dunk dunk
dun dun ch well my son probably about
five or six at the time he called it the
blood on your face song you got blood on
your face you're a big disgrace but my
daughter she's you know three at the
time my daughter was calling it the baby
song and it would come on she go oh oh
the baby song is on the baby song is on
and we
no idea why she was calling it the baby
song until about two weeks later it
dawned on us we will we will rock you so
here she is she knows the sign rock but
she's not sophisticated with language
enough to know that rock could mean to
rock or to rock she doesn't know that
yet but she's making meaning with it she
makes it wrong she doesn't make it
correctly but she actually is
constructing meaning so when we asked
her if she wanted to go see the movie
how to train your dragon she said yes
will there be a choo-choo in it she
again isn't sophisticated with language
enough to know that train could mean to
prepare to teach or it could mean big
iron machine that goes on tracks but
she's constructing meaning now
bouchard's point actually is that were
so bombarded by images that this
structure gets broken down that the sign
to the thing that signifies gets broken
down and we actually choose the sign the
image becomes more important so another
example there's my son good so you guys
can take a cue alright so there's my son
and he was about four at this time and
there's this picture here is this
idyllic picture of him running it was at
a wedding we were at this like kitschy
wedding in Wisconsin at this old
farmhouse and he's running in this field
with this other little girl chasing him
and it's beautiful and when I think back
to that wedding that's what I remember
the truth of that event if I can get
back to it is he was a little pain and I
wanted to strangle a kid he once sit
down he won't do anything but it doesn't
matter anymore because it's captured in
the image and I would rather live in the
image than the real experience itself
when we want a lot of us so that Bulger
x point is the sign becomes disconnected
from the thing that signifies that we
actually choose the image over the real
thing and of course the greatest example
of this is advertising I mean who cares
what the thing does it's what the thing
means we talk to kids at your youth
group the next time you meet and ask
them if they wear the tennis shoes they
wear because well they have good souls
and they're going to last a long time
it's a good value no you put that Nike
swoosh on because of what it means that
it's a sign that you take on for
actually what it means kids wear what
they wear because of actually what it
means so I want to show you just a
couple minutes of a documentary that
gets that this sign becoming
disconnected from the thing that
signifies and it comes from a front line
listen for how the side becomes
disconnected from the thing it signifies
today we're all but unthinkable so has
never smelled this good before and
neither have you ads laid claim to real
tangible differences between one product
and another brands they were based on
what I call ER words whiter brighter
cleaner stronger smooth as mild as an
atheist watch any commercials on
American TV you'll see these words up in
the first three seconds hammered
remorselessly into your brain but at
some point these words cease to have
meaning we no longer believed that one
product was any brighter or cleaner than
any other everything works now you know
french fries taste crisp coffee's hot
you know beer tastes good unless you
live in America and then you know you
can only one get but all these things
now at table stakes by the early 1990s a
new approach to marketing came to the
floor one that left right over what the
product did to what the product meant
you know it's not just a car it's an
expression of the culture anesthetic
that is connected somehow to nature
these were the super brands like Nike
Starbucks the body shop and what they
noticed these brands had in common was
that they were they they were engaging
in a kind of a sort of pseudo spiritual
marketing
so nike said that they were about the
meaning of sports but more than that but
they were about transcendence through
sports Starbuck said that they were
about the idea of community place that
is a third place that is not home not
work benetton was for selling
multiculturalism racial diversity this
lesson that a brand could forge an
emotional even spiritual bond with
today's cynical consumer wasn't lost on
corporate America when I was a brand
manager Procter & Gamble my job is
basically to make sure the product is
good developed new advertising copy
designer pack now bro manager has an
entirely different kind of
responsibility in fact they have more
responsibility their job now is to
create a maintain a whole meaning system
for people through its they get identity
and understanding of the world their job
now is to be a community leader this
summer invited everyone who owns a
Saturn visit us in Tennessee replace
their car was gone and that's the object
of emotional branding to fill the empty
places where non-commercial institutions
like schools and churches might have
once done the job brands become more
than just a mark of quality they become
an invitation to a longed for lifestyle
a ready-made identity when you listen to
brand managers talk you can get quite
carried away in this idea that they
actually are fulfilling these needs that
we have for community and narrative and
and transcendence but but in the end it
is you know a laptop and a pair of
running shoes and you they might be
great but they're not actually going to
fulfill those those need so you see the
point that the sign becomes disconnected
from the thing it signifies what matters
is the image not the real thing anymore
it's it's a pretty profound line when he
says and that's the point of emotional
branding to fill the places where once
noncommercial institutions like churches
and schools used to and I have to admit
this for myself when I'm on an airplane
and I have to talk to somebody which I
usually put up every sign that says I
don't speak the language don't talk to
me but when I have to talk to somebody I
would much rather talk to them about
apple and new iphone then I would want
to talk to them about my
family or my church that I would much
rather do that that we get sucked into
this but Beaudry arts point is that
these are often especially when it comes
to advertising they're just signs
they're supposed to signify things but
now they become disconnected and the
sign becomes the point they're supposed
to be pathways but now they become the
very currency we use to construct
meaning with so this leaves us into the
it's not that there's no meaning but
there's so much meaning to construct
their these signs that are free-floating
that we use to construct meaning and we
end up using prepared realities to
construct meaning and by prepared
realities I mean the things that we see
on sound stages and on websites they
become what we use to actually construct
meaning so for instance people know tend
to know more about their favorite
celebrity or their favorite sports stars
young people do for sure then they know
about their family history they tend to
know those narratives more than they
know the narratives of their own history
it's interesting and cultural studies
they've done this research in the field
of cultural studies and they found that
they went into some community some
Eastern European communities and they
interviewed people after a certain major
cliffhanger it happened in the local
soap opera so it's a soap opera so you
know something really terrible happened
like someone fell down a well and at the
bottom of the well was a tiger in their
evil twin you know like something really
plausible happened but this was you know
what happened in the local soap opera
the interesting thing is they would
interview the village pastor and the
village pastor would get prayer requests
not for the actress but for the
character of the soap opera that that
the the church prayer requests were
being filled by prayer requests for this
this actor so what's real and what's not
real that we kind of confuse this
there's a pop star named Lily Allen and
she has this song called the fear and
she's very well known in the UK and you
may not know her here which makes me
feel really cool Lexi this is a UK
artist that you don't know about but she
has a song called of fear and this is
one of the line she says life's about
film stars unless about mothers and she
says but it doesn't matter because I'm
packing plastic and that's what makes my
life so effing fantastic now it is
always dangerous to exegete a pop stars
lyrics
but at the first line the first thing
that we know is a lice more about film
stars and less about mothers I mean in a
real way that's true for her I mean
Angelina Jolie has a new movie every 9
to 16 months her mother well she lives
with her for a while then she kicks her
out because she's going to move in with
this guy and then she moves went with
her with someone else and then she was
back with her mom but then her mom moves
away I mean Angelina Jolie or a brad
Pitt movie those are more consistent
than her own family the hyper-real is
more real than her own family but then
she says it doesn't matter cuz i'm
packing plastic like i said we probably
shouldn't exegete this but it means one
of two things either she has a credit
card with a major credit limit on it or
she has had her breasts enhanced and
that becomes the Met that becomes the
measure of what makes her life so
fantastic again the unreal becomes the
measure of what's real or this show all
of us have seen friends right I was much
more of a Seinfeld the guy when they
were on my wife though was huge into
friends she loved friends and we were
living in la at the time and she
actually went to a couple tapings of
friends and one night we were watching
it right in the right when it was at its
best and Seinfeld was going to follow it
and after a great episode my wife lean
back on the couch and gave the sigh of
satisfaction and said I just love this
show I just feel like Rachel and Phoebe
are my friends and I gave her this look
like you will never live that comment
down and so I gave her the needle every
chance i could and at that time burp the
Burbank Airport when you would land in
it they actually had like cardboard
cutouts of celebrities that when you
look through your window you can look
into the terminal and you could see them
and I had the friends characters
whenever we land in burbank i would
nudge car and say car your friends are
here to welcome you back that she never
ever heard she didn't like that but she
also was in a baby group when our kids
were young in our neighborhood these
parents would get together and
commiserate on raising small toddlers
and you know spike their coffee to get
through the day and 11 week this woman
comes in she's as I gotta tell you the
story says I'm so embarrassed by this so
that was at work this week and it was a
monday and i was in my cubicle and a
friend of mine came up to me and told me
what they had done over the weekend and
it just triggered something in me
immediately and i said oh my gosh oh my
gosh
that happened to one of my friends and
she said I started telling them what had
happened to one of my friends that
connected or what happened to them and
she said about halfway through to my
shock I turned white and I started to
sweat because I realized I was not
telling a story of something that
happened to one of my friends I was
recapping a plot from the TV show
friends that the meaning had been
blurred that she actually felt more
connected to the narratives she saw in
these prepared realities then through
her own nerves and she could she had a
hard time distinguishing what one was
real in what one wasn't that these
things get blended which is baudrillard
point so simulation now becomes life and
we make meaning with simulation not
necessary with the real but with
simulations simulations like models and
celebrities in web pages and profiles I
mean if you work with particularly
junior high young women you know this is
true in the sense that a model is not a
real woman's body a model is a
simulation of a real woman's body but
nearly every 15 year old girl wishes
their body looked like the simulation
and you can talk to them for days you
can cut out as many pictures out of a
magazine and and paste it on a piece of
paper but you're always shocked because
you can get done teaching about this and
then they get one comment that they're
fat and it crumble or they and they can
even say through their tears I know this
shouldn't matter to me I know it doesn't
matter but it just hurts so bad because
they live in a cultural context where
the image is the real the image is what
matters so you can logically tell them
it shouldn't matter but the simulation
has become what's captivating in what
they make meaning with and again it's
only a simulation it is not a real
woman's body but it becomes the measure
of what actually is real and we should
be careful not to think oh these dumb
kids this is just young people this is
true in presidential politics you don't
have a chance to be at least after the
the Nixon Kennedy debate you don't have
a chance to be President if you don't
what first and foremost look
presidential you have to look
presidential I don't know if you guys
remember back in the dark ages of the oj
cultural trial in the oj chase remember
the oj chase and some of you are too
young to
remember that but oj got in to his white
Bronco and went through the streets of
brentwood and then got on the 405 and
had headed down if you lived in la poste
the oj trial it changed everything
because this was the first time
extensively that they had a helicopter
over and would they broke into regular
broadcasting and now after that they
realized that the numbers went up for
car chases so if you live in LA even now
it they'll break into they'll break into
the Super Bowl for a car chase I mean
that because people voyeuristically want
to watch this but one of the most
interesting things is they did a
research study because they notice when
AJ was going through and his white
Bronco through the streets of brentwood
that people were running out on the
street with handheld TV sets waving at
the camera above so they got some of
these people and they interviewed them
and asked them why they did that well
what they found is that people said that
the reason they ran out on the street
was because they thought this was a
historical event and then I asked him
why did you bring it handheld TV set
with you and they basically articulated
that they needed the TV set to to to
articulate to the TV set to verify that
they were having an historical event
that it wasn't a true historical event
unless it was on TV in the same thing
happened when the Berlin Wall came down
the people ran out with handheld TV sets
that the TV that the image verified the
real that it became more real than the
real thing so when this happens
Baudrillard says we enter into the realm
of a simulacrum now unless you're a
vocab nerd you either think this is one
of those fancy made-up academic words or
else you know you don't know that this
is actually a real word and actually a
simulacra is simply by definition it's a
simulation that's lost its trail of
breadcrumbs back from its original so
it's a simulation that we no longer
connect back to its original the best
example of this of course is your
computer Apple and the Macintosh changed
everything in computing because it use
simulations to make their operating
system so if I even set you right now
like oh I had a handout for you guys but
I left it on my desktop most of you your
minds would not go to some hard desktop
some real desktop you would go right to
Mike you think of my computer screen or
if I said oh I had that but I left it in
a file you wouldn't think oh it's in
some
I'll in a photo or in a in a cabinet you
would think oh yeah on his computer that
it's become a simulacra it was a it was
originally just a simulation but now our
minds immediately go to that so think of
this in the context of our young people
a show like the hills which this was a
huge show particular with young adults
becomes a simulacrum now young people
watch this show about these young adults
in the Hollywood Hills to figure out
what it means to be a young adult I mean
they already are a young adult but they
use this as the very measure for what it
means to be a young adult or think of
this show newport harbor which now i'm
just confessing my MTV sins to you so
you can pray for me it was on MTV it was
actually a spin-off of Laguna Beach
which actually the hills is a spin-off
of that but you don't need to know that
you just need to know i watch way too
much TV but it's all for research
purposes but this was a show about these
high school kids in newport california
and then for the most part they were
just regular kids i mean they were
beautiful but there are beautiful kids
in every high school in America they
lived in a beautiful place in newport
beach but what of course happens is mtv
shows up it records their life it edit
sit down makes it into an image edits it
down into 22 minutes broadcasts it
around the country and these are no
longer kids these are images images that
other kids consume to figure out what it
means to be a kid I mean they already
are kids they are real kids what they
use the image to figure out what to wear
how to talk what what they should think
about certain things that this becomes a
simulacra and becomes so weird now that
there's layers and layers of simulation
that after these shows you can go on to
MTV calm and play a video game where you
hang out with these people which I just
don't get maybe I'm too old for this or
something but I understand playing a
video game where you're a wide receiver
for the jets or you get to kill vampires
or something but I don't get playing a
video game where you get to be a kid I
mean you already are a kid but no you
can get to go in there and they give you
like five hundred virtual MTV bucks to
hang out with these people so watch this
this is at the very end of the hills and
watch the levels of simulation on this
next time you're running the show really
important I am counting on you to make
this a success does have me happy 21st
birthday Bunney
390 people 15 them okay they said we're
ready to search Lauren here we go you
can dance party try on new fashions and
enter the hills rewind content you could
win 500 virtual MTV [ __ ] I Whitney come
hang out with me in the virtual help all
right those are some intense levels of
simulation so they that show itself is a
simulation and then you can go and play
a video game where you what's the appeal
we're actually you become a sign and
interact with these other signs and I
think this says a lot about how
celebrity culture works and if there's
one thing true about our culture and
true about the young people that we work
with that celebrity culture is huge and
the thing about a celebrity is that a
celebrity isn't for the most part is no
longer a person a celebrity is a sign a
celebrity is a sign that we use to
consume to figure out how we should cut
our hair how we should act how we should
talk and that makes them incredibly
powerful but it doesn't necessarily make
them people their signs that we consume
to figure these things out it's
interesting I think when you ask most
young people my own son is this way what
he really wants to be when he grows up
and you talk to young people you work
with everybody you know this culture is
built on it's really important to be
rich that you really want to be rich
rich is good but more importantly than
being rich in this cultural context is
being a celebrity because if you're a
celebrity you have real power because
now people consume your image to figure
out how to how to walk how to talk how
to act that becomes incredibly
significant I don't know now I'm really
confessing my MTV sins but did anyone
ever watch my super sweet 16 you know
the show some of you that know what are
laughing it is it was a very
stomach-turning show it was about these
mainly young women and they were all 15
turning 16 and we're gonna have their
sweet 16 birthday party and their
parents were filthy rich so they would
spend between 20 and two hundred
thousand dollars on this sweet 16 party
and so these girls were already very
very wealthy but the most interesting
thing about almost every one of the
shows is the way these young women would
construct their birthday party was they
would construct it for them to be a
celebrity they would have a photo shoot
they would arrive on a white hole
worse they would actually bring in their
other parents pay for some artists to
sing at their birthday party and they
would get up on stage with them that it
wasn't enough just to be rich but to be
actually a celebrity now this will not
i'm going to give you a warning this
will not hold up in a court of law so
don't try this but it may just be
actually that the celebrity stalker does
something more healthy than the rest of
us again this won't hold up in the court
of law so don't be thinking I love Brad
Pitt I thank you i'm going to go stalk
him right now but the interesting thing
about the celebrity stalker is the
celebrity stalker says I love Brad Pitt
I have every one of his pictures on my
wall I've read everything about him I
love Brad Pitt I demand the sign signify
itself so you drive to Hollywood you go
through his garbage you wait for him
outside of his his compound and you try
to interact with them the rest of us we
don't do that we we just figured that
it's a sign we consume it and when we're
done with it we discard it we don't
actually ask the sign to signify itself
which is why we can so easily discard
them when we're done with them like
Britney Spears Britney Spears where we
can't wait for Britney Spears to have
another implosion and go crazy because
she's not a real person she's a sign
that we can consume and get rid of
quickly so it may just be that the
celebrity stalker actually does
something healthier than the rest of us
but like I said that won't hold up in
the court of law so don't say hey this
guy at Yale Divinity School said that
this was a healthy thing to do won't
work it's interesting that Baudrillard
himself gotten a lot of trouble because
he wrote an op-ed during the first Iraq
war in the Paris newspaper and he
actually said the Iraq war the first
Iraq war he says it is not happening it
is not real in his reason he said that
of course made people incredibly angry
because real money was being spent real
people were dying but his point is this
war is being fought on video screens
first and foremost but the second main
point of his op-ed was a case that
happened that he encountered on CNN that
CNN was in Atlanta interviewing a
general to talk about what was happening
on the ground in Iraq and they were
talking about it and then they said now
let's go on the ground in Kuwait with
our embedded reporters and they went on
the ground and something happened with
the feed and they caught the CNN
reporters watching CNN to report what
was happening on the ground and
Beaudry's point is what is real life has
become about consuming images to consume
images is there anything real in
minutes to this at all so the truth is
we've always had these simulations it's
just now that the simulation that we now
choose to live in the simulation more
than a real life and we have people who
would rather live inside simulations in
the real life my son we allow him to
he's really into TV and he's really into
video games and we allowed him when he
was five or six to play a half hour of
star wars lego every weekend day and I
don't we figure I don't know if you've
ever seen this the lego games it makes
you as a parent feel good like my kids
shooting things but they're just Legos
and it's classic justification but we
let him play for a half hour but it was
my terrible job to go upstairs and turn
off the PlayStation when he was done and
the the five-year-old rage was intense
and one day I turned it off and he
looked at me with the greatest
frustration he could find and he said
daddy daddy real life isn't fun I wish I
could just live inside star wars lego I
just wish I could live inside of it and
you think about that that there's ways
that people actually really believe that
we really desire that and the image
becomes so full-blown that were sucked
into it I want to show you a very
humorous clip that comes from the onion
that talks about these simulations on
top of simulations
video game players celebrated this week
as a hotly anticipated sequel to the
popular online video game world of
warcraft hit the shelves onion news
network tech trends has the story world
of warcraft it has nine million players
worldwide many who say they spend
hundreds of hours playing the game every
week here at the blizzard entertainment
offices creators say they couldn't be
any more excited about the new expansion
pack world of world of warcraft jonathan
parishes the vice president of blizzard
entertainment world of warcraft allows
workout gamers to do what they like to
do more than anything else in life which
is the world warcraft blizzard program
or chris boldmann demonstrated how the
game works so here i'm playing as a
character named greg playing world of
warcraft as a level 3 peligro so i'm
going to press my up arrow key and
that's going to make him press his up
arrow key we're just going to make the
character on his screen kind of move
forward across the screen what this game
is going to do is put you in the shoes
of someone imagining their in the shoes
of an elephant dwarf a mage a troll the
fan response has been great the game
sold over 100,000 copies its first day
of release my avatar is the biggest
world of warcraft fan in the whole world
of world of warcraft world the game
promises level of realism to video
gaming never before seen here i'm going
to press alt shift 7 and that's going to
make my character start scrolling
through the Terms of Use Agreement and
it's fun to just play a character who's
getting lost in this whole other sort of
fantasy world the graphics are amazing
the revolutionary I mean when you when
you're staring at the computer screen
you actually believe that you're in a
dimly lit basements staring at a
computer screen with each
you're just like oh my god it sounds
exactly like the keystrokes that I know
from my own personal experience of
hitting Keys based on the gangs big
success Blizzard Entertainment is
already looking ahead to their next
release plan for fall of two thousand
nine fans love world a world of warcraft
and we know they're going to want their
characters to be able to play the game
as well so we've already started work on
world a world of warcraft world of
warcraft writing for The Onion News
Network I'm Jeff Tate when we come back
and Atlanta man mauled by a pitbull
puppy describes the adorable attack
alright so i think you get you get the
point this is that the simulation
becomes so full-blown that we actually
live inside of it i mean they're making
fun of the fact that it ran new stories
of young people who were losing jobs not
going to school because they just wanted
to live inside of these games and felt
more comfortable inside of them so
simulation has overcome the real and
maybe this is one of the reasons
actually especially if you've been in
seminary classes and Old Testament
seminary class or to learn Hebrew and or
know people can kind of conservative
traditional Jews that one of the things
you're not supposed to say the name
Yahweh because I think they understood
that the name that the sign could be
disconnected from the thing that
signifies that if you just flip Utley
say it over and over again you can
disconnect it or when young people say
things like you know I don't like to
share my clothes I'm just a real Nazi
when it comes to my clothes then it's
over that Nazi no longer refers to
totalitarian government that
exterminated over six million people it
means you're kind of mean and you're
kind of grumpy so it might just be that
some of the most dangerous things we can
allow our kids to actually consume and
participate in our things like this and
I know every young pastor loves the
kitchen Jesus stuff because it's so
humorous but you start to wonder if the
sign of Jesus has the white guy with
perfectly conditioned hair overtakes the
real and all of a sudden who Jesus is is
just this simulation of this kind of a
religious person that doesn't mean
anything anymore so when simulation
becomes more captivating than the real
we enter into what's called the hyper
real we find ourselves in the hyper real
now I don't know if any of you are
football fans but two seasons ago
samsung was advertising their TV on
every commercial break of the NFL that
the new their new flats
rain 1 inch TV which did make me want it
deeply but I love TV but their whole
point was moved from the real to the
hyper real and they meant this is like a
positive marketing hook but actually
baudrillard means it as a negative thing
that we winter into the hyper real it
becomes really hard for us to determine
actually what is real itself so example
of the hyper real skip and I were
talking about he loves 30 rock and
there's a great line from 30 rock if you
ever seen the NBC show 30 rock Alec
Baldwin plays Jack Donaghy who's the
kind of CEO it was of GE now it's cable
town or whatever and a tina fey is
running this show and so Tina Fey Tina
Fey's character Liz Lemon is in with
Alec Baldwin and Alec Baldwin's
character Jack Donaghy says Liz Lemon do
you understand that I have front row
seats to the Yankees to the Knicks into
the Rangers do you know what that's like
that's like having a huge HDTV screen
right in front of your face the
hyper-real and even Apple now is
advertising the new Retina screen is
finer than the human eye can pick up and
you wonder when we'll just want to walk
around and see the world through our
images themselves or maybe a more
real-life example of this when the
shrine to Jerry Jones open the Dallas
Cowboy Stadium and they had their first
preseason game they ran into two
problems and they both had to do with
the scoreboard the first was that the
kicker kept kicking the ball under the
scoreboard but they refused to move the
scoreboard because the scoreboard was
constructed on to 60 yard HD fully 1080
wonderful screens but the bigger issue
was that when they were playing the game
they realized very quickly they could
not put the live coverage up on the
screen because everyone in the stadium
was no longer watching the real game
that was happening there but they were
watching the screen so now if you go
they will just put the score up on the
screen and only show replays on it
because people were choosing the
simulation over the real life so I don't
know if it if any of you have watched
the show a baby story has anyone seen
this TLC the baby story it's very
sentimental and my wife and I got really
hooked on it well actually she got
really hooked on it when she was
pregnant with our with our son and I
would watch it to be supportive and at
the end of it it's so yes it's so
sentimental that you know it's it my she
would cry every time
I was being supportive and I would sit
in the corner try not to cry this is
stupid you know as I try not to cry it's
very sentimental it's about 22 minutes
before the first commercial you meet the
woman and hear about her plans for the
pregnancy then after the first
commercial the babies she goes in labor
the baby's born commercial then the last
couple minutes our homecoming well we
were into the show and we went to our
cars Midwife appointment and our mid
wife's name was Ursula Ursula was
originally from Germany and she was she
spit nails I mean she was tough tough
tough and so we were in there and she
was getting some paperwork ready and I
decided I should you know have a little
small talk so I said hey Ursula do you
ever watch the baby story in her neck
turn around and she looked at me and she
said I hate that show I hate it I was
like oh my gosh she's gonna kill me
right here this is how I died right in
this office and she realized she
probably was a little bit to attend so
she should explain what she means she
doesn't know really really really I hate
that show and she says you know as a
midwife I've had a number of experiences
where my job as a midwife is to give the
woman the kind of pregnancy she wants to
have him with every woman I will make a
plan with her how she wants this
pregnancy to go and she says it's
happened to me on a number of occasions
where the baby will be born and I always
give the woman and her partner enough
time to kind of have their experience
and I come back about a half hour 45
minutes later to check on the woman and
also to make sure that she's had the
kind of experience she said so I'll come
back into the room and I'll say to the
woman I'll say so how were things when
woman will say what it was fine no no
wait a minute you seem less than satisfy
this what happened no no really really
it's nothing it's nothing no really
please tell me what what's wrong no no
III can't it's nothing no really it's my
job as your midwife to give you the kind
of experience you want please tell me it
will help me with other women well I
don't know please well it's just it's
just I don't know it's just that it it
was nothing like the baby story
so now I have never given birth believe
it or not but I've lived through two of
them and I know they don't happen in 22
minutes the baby story is a simulation
of a woman's labor but it now becomes
the measure of the real event I when I
do this maybe some of you are this is
starting to ring a bell for you but
often when I've done this talk with
pastors in the room they'll run up to me
after and say this is exactly what I
experienced when a wedding goes wrong
when I have an experience where wedding
goes wrong it's usually some kind of
experience there's some Hollywood
wedding there's some Kate and Wills
wedding so God have mercy on your soul
if you did a wedding you know a number
of months ago that that becomes the
measure of the real thing you enter into
the hyper real and this works with how
we read the biblical texts with young
people as well I remember this dates me
as well but when I was at in youth
ministry at one point we were doing a
bible study and we were reading the
psalm and we walked through the valley
of the shadow of death and every kid in
my small group said wait a minute that's
not the Bible that's coolios gangsters
paradise that's what that is and in a
sense it's true for them it is Coolio's
gangsta's Paradise because that's what
they've made meaning with and now it
becomes my job they have to re redo the
structure to put the structure back
together again now why does this matter
actually we've done a little cute
academic little walk but why does this
actually matter well it matters for a
few things is that when we lose this
boundary between the sign of the thing
that signifies it becomes harder to
construct meaning because some things
get blended together and the first thing
that gets blended together is the real
and the fake it becomes harder to tell
what is real in what is fake and you can
just see some examples of this in our
larger pop culture I'm a big fan of the
Sacha Baron Cohen movies borat and and
Bruno I think they're incredibly funny
but if you've ever watched them you know
it is a completely mind spinning thing
of what's real and what's not Sacha
Baron Cohen is playing a character but
everyone else in the movie are they're
real people and it's it's a plane with
what's real or what's not or The Colbert
Report which i'm a big fan of The
Colbert Report as well but the
interesting thing is Stephen Colbert is
now taken that character away from the
show itself in onto university campuses
and start the start of the super PAC and
you don't know who and he says he's just
playing a character he's just playing a
character of a right-wing pundit but it
transcends the show itself so who is
siva cool
see the character is he not he's
actually raising real money in the super
PAC what's real and what's not real
because uh yeah yeah yeah and you it's a
blending of what's real and what's not
or it becomes harder to decide what is a
subject and what's an object now maybe
this sounds a little prudish but when I
you know even when I was a kid
pornography was not part of pop culture
no late-night talk show person would say
oh yeah you know I watched five hours of
pornography on the internet this you
know this last week well there wasn't an
internet but you get my point but now
pornography has become part of pop
culture and I think it is this blending
of the subject and the object it becomes
harder to determine when the sign
becomes disconnected from the thing to
signifies or maybe something really in
our election season is the true and the
false with 24-hour news you start to
realize it doesn't matter if it's MSNBC
or its Fox News that you start to
realize real quickly they don't care
about what's true or false they just
care that I keep consuming images that I
speak keep watching the advertisement it
becomes hard to determine what's real
and fought false we lose these
boundaries so Lily Allen our pop star
says this she says I'm a weapon of
massive consumption it's not my fault
it's how I'm programmed to function
which is an interesting comment and then
she says this was I think it's quite
profound I want to give her too much
credit but I think it's a profound
statement she says but I'm not a sinner
she says but I'm not a sinner but I'm
not a I'm not a saint but I'm not a
sinner now everything's cool as long as
I'm getting thinner it's a pretty
profound statement again I don't want to
give her too much credit but it does
ring a bell for us those of us in the
church I mean the church for it may two
thousand years or so we could kind of
assume that maybe people didn't like it
all the time but they kind of cared if
they were good or bad if they're going
to heaven or hell if they were saying
earlier sinner and I get I don't want to
give her too much credit but she just
simply says I don't care those
categories this they don't make any
difference to me it doesn't matter in
ultimate what matters to me what I'm
actually living for is my image am I
getting thinner that has more
existential depth to me than any of
these categories you have and I think we
do run a problem within the church and
again I don't want to give her too much
credit but we keep on talking about you
should care
about these categories you should care
about these theological categories and
it's not that young people don't care
about the church or even don't care
about religion but it's not that they
hate it actually as researchers tell us
it's simply that they don't find
anything they can make meaning with
because they're trying to construct
meaning around what their body looks
like or they're trying to construct
meaning in this different way and we
keep on saying you should care about
this and they're just like I I don't
know I might be a saint I might be a
sinner I don't care everything's cool as
long as I'm getting thinner and it means
that we really have to change and it
also means that what we do in youth
ministry is incredibly important because
our the way that we construct and
articulate and proclaim the gospel
becomes incredibly significant against
this backdrop and most people the church
just keep on saying oh these categories
people still care about them people
still care about them but we know a lot
of us that'll young people they just
don't so how do we imagine we proclaim
the gospel in categories that make sense
within this cultural context well how do
we you know how do we think about this
well I mean one thing's only on points
to is again is it's not that there's no
meaning it's its debts there's almost
too much meaning to construct and
baudrillard says this kind of in his
great French overstatement but he says
he says we are witnesses to an
unprecedented evaporation of the ground
of meaning the quest for some division
between the real and the unreal or even
the true in the untrue and the immoral
is futile or the moral and immoral is
futile now that's that's some pretty
strong words and bo jared is a good
french philosopher so he says let's just
drink wine and die you know there's
nothing no point let's just drink wine
and die so how do we think about this in
the context of the church and especially
if Lily Allen signals some pretty
significant cultural changes that leave
some of our categories that we've held
on to theologically as not unimportant
or not as as not as something that young
people hate but that they simply just
think don't make any sense to them well
I wonder if we think of this little
place may be the happiest place on earth
Disneyland isn't actually helpful
actually baudrillard talks about
disneyland in his book stimulation in
simulacra if you've ever been to a
Disney theme park the most interesting
thing about it what is the first thing
you encounter when you go to Disneyland
after you pay eighty dollars to park
your car what's the next thing that you
encounter when you go ahead what's up
pictures yep but you go through Main
Street right like that's the first thing
after you go through the interesting
thing is Main Street is a simulacra in
most American cities and where there are
very few main streets but in the main
street was a simulation of America
Americana means you but it doesn't
really exist anymore and if you spend
time in Disneyland everything within it
is a simulation everything almost if
anything that if you go over if you're
at Disneyland you go over to Tom
Sawyer's Island which has now been
rebranded as pirates of the caribbean
island and you spend ninety dollars for
a small coke and a french fry and go
over over there to have a picnic with
your kids any tree over there that your
kids could actually climb on is not a
real treat it's cast plastic anything
you can touch and feel is not real and
even the older rides that are that use
real trees and real bushes they've been
cut and colored towards the hyper-real
so they're fluorescent pink or yellow
nothing is real now we made a terrible
parenting mistake a number of years ago
doubt because Owen was about three and a
half amazin was about six to nine months
like that picture you saw and we decided
we were in Anaheim so we would take them
to Disneyland really bad mistake I think
you need to be seven or eight to
understand the magic of the Magic
Kingdom and I knew I was in trouble when
I took the boy into the bathroom after
two days of trying to convince him that
this was a really great experience all
the money i was spending and i took him
into the bathroom and he put his hand
under the faucet in the water started
and he took his hand away from the
faucet and it stopped and he wanted to
spend 20 minutes doing this and thought
this was a coolest thing ever and i'm
saying the nemo ride is outside don't
want to go to the nemo ride and I knew I
should have just took a kid to the mall
after that experience and I like I was
saved me a ton of money so we took our
kids and we were trying to convince him
to have a good time and they were deep
into the wines and now you're really you
know you're your own father comes out of
you like I spent all this money and this
is how you're going to act so we decided
we needed a ride that would be low key
that we could kind of stuff some sugar
and our kids and take a deep breath and
so we could kind of break the whiny the
whining that was going on so we were
walking into frontierland and there's
this high school girl up front and she
had her little disney hat on and her
cane and she was yelling the tiki room
is open the tiki room is open so I
walked up to her San what's the Tiki
Room so now it's a bird show
okay so we walked into this room which
is probably a quarter of the size of
this room and there was a there was a
net on the ceiling but it was impeccably
clean and I thought man Disney cleans up
quickly after bird show and I knew that
was true was Disney like if you get
bored at a disney park you throw popcorn
on the ground and go one one-thousand
two one-thousand somebody will come up
and sweep it up before you get to 15 so
i thought wow Disney I mean this is
spectacular how quickly they clean up so
it gets in here to the show and the high
school girl comes in and I'm thinking
myself they are gonna let a high school
girl run this bird show this is these
are like killer predator birds and she's
sure enough she does she says we're
ready to begin ting ting ting puts her
cane down on the ground she says Pedro
begin in Pedro a green parrot starts the
bird show but Pedro comes out of the
wall and he's not a real bird he's
better than a real bird he's an
animatronic robot bird who tells jokes
and dances and now the walls are alive
and these are this is a great birch oh I
mean these things actually sing and
dance and they don't poop I mean there's
no mess it's perfectly pristine it was
an incredible you know incredible
experience so after about 15 minutes
it's over but my kids are still really
whining I mean the wines have set and
deeply so we know we need to take a
break so we walk out and we see a sign
to a petting zoo and we have to follow
these fake big orange cast rocks but we
follow it around and we round the corner
and we see it and it scares the hell out
of me it was a real goat a real go and
then I'll pick I know we need to stop
for an announcement so I we will pick it
up there with the real goat could not be
in the space we wouldn't be able to have
youth ministry now program we wouldn't
be here we're not the support of the
Dean and I want you to introduce you to
a really great friend of ministry and
youth ministry in a lifetime pastor Dean
Greg sterling
I just wanted to say welcome on behalf
of the Divinity School to all of you you
are playing an absolutely vital role in
the future of Christianity you probably
know the statistics as well as I do but
fifty percent of the people who've grown
up in mainline Protestant denominations
have left fifty percent of the American
populace is I believe under the age of
30 for you in your work represent where
the future of Christianity lies and one
of our ambitions is to help make sure
that Christianity which engages society
rationally and is open to society into
that engagement is alive and well and I
think you play an absolutely vital role
in that I salute you for your work we're
grateful you're here and I wish you the
very best a special thank you to Andy
for coming and for participating and
leading the discussion for his special
talents and his work with you and I will
also say a special word of commendation
to skip it's been phenomenally
successful at new canaan and he helps
the center for faith in cultures but he
also helps the Divinity School is on our
board of advisers so it's a real
pleasure to work with skip to have Andy
here and to say a very warm welcome to
all of you god bless you in your work
you will be in my prayers and I hope
that I will be in yours thank you very
much
so like I said we round this corner and
there it was this goat it was a real
goat now I'm not somebody who's freaked
out by animals or anything but I would
notice myself as I walked up to this
petting zoo and I kept walking up in
seeing this goat that would nudge car
and say Cara look at a goat it's real
she thought I was on drugs or something
like yes that's a real good but it
actually did really freaked me out and I
went up to it and I kind of touch it
like I said I'm not like sheepish around
animals see see the fun you get it and I
but I wouldn't went it went to touch
this goat in I felt myself kind of
nervous bite and I think what had
happened is I had spent so much time
saturated in the hyper-real that when
reality punctured it when reality showed
up I didn't know what to do and it was
actually a real shock to my being when
we think about this in the context of
our youth ministries I mean one of the
ways we could take this is say well our
young people live in on this hyper real
image based society so what we need to
do is we need to compete in the hyper
real that we need to make our youth
groups as hyper real as we can you got
to get a really great website you've got
to make yourself a really sexy avatar I
don't know you got to do something to
compete within the hyper real and you
can try it and let me know how it goes
but my guess is it's not going to go too
well or maybe the way we imagined what
we do in our youth groups and even in
our churches is to articulate and give
space for young people to search for God
up against the real that when the goat
shows up like when they say my parents
just told me they're getting a divorce
or when the young woman says I know I
should care about my body but I just
hate the way I look that reality
punctures that this becomes the place
where we I think we really start to talk
about faith we start to wrestle with it
if the church's job is to compete with
the hyper-real I don't think it's going
to happen and to be quite honest the
irony of this presentation is we've been
talking about images and I've been
showing you nothing but images then some
sense there's no way out of this and no
one's taking my TV away necessarily but
we have to find a way to dig deep into
the faith in our
ticular the faith up against this hyper
real and I don't think it's necessarily
an idea of competition but a way to talk
about when reality punctures the hyper
real because at some point it will at
some point your boyfriend will leave you
at some point you're one of your parents
may get sick and often when young people
have those experiences they don't end up
finding the church as a place to
articulate those to find hope in the
midst of those two actually wrestle with
those it's very interesting that our pop
star Lily Allen I've shown you her her
vs. but her course is this it's a it
says please replace the lamp but on top
of that it says I don't know what's
right or what's real anymore which is
interesting she doesn't say I don't know
what's right or wrong she says I don't
know what's right or real anymore I
don't know how I'm meant to feel anymore
when do you think it will all become
clear because I'm being overtaken by the
fear her question isn't what's morally
right what's morally wrong she's she's
not about that but she does have a deep
question what's real Who am I where is
my being held these are actually her
questions of being where do I belong
where who holds me what does it mean for
me to be me what is my lifetime and why
do I live it and I think our ministries
have to pull into this depth with young
people especially in a hyper real world
two stories and I'm gonna show you one
more film clip and we'll be done but
it's interesting that Parker Palmer
reports this study that had been done
and I think it's an interesting
connection for us that a study was done
at university campuses on what it was
that allowed undergraduates to really
like a class like what was it in the
class that led them to really like it
and they didn't know what it was so they
would interview them and they thought
maybe it was the content so they would
interview students who had just finished
physics 101 and they asked them did you
like physics I mean did you like this
classes I love this class well did you
like physics no I will never take
another faces class again I I know and
then I thought well maybe it was
performance so they said so did you like
this class yes I like this class well
did you do well in it knew I barely
passed like I had to get you know I had
to get AC on the last exam to pass to
pass so they they probed and probed and
they decided there was one variable that
determine if an undergraduate like the
class or not
and the one variable is this the
students perception that it mattered to
the professor it's fascinating part of
the problem with mainline loss part of
the problem as the Dean articulated of
the loss of young people within the main
line is they're just not so sure this
matters to us they're just not so sure
and some things they wonder I don't
think this is more tasks it than
explicit but sometimes I wonder if the
youth ministry itself exists just to be
a holding pen for them not to have to
face the real as it as it crushes into
their life if it's a way to actually
hide them from having to face it and I
think one of the turns that we take
especially in a hyper real world is to
really make this the curriculum that we
reflect on with young people and it has
to matter to us we have to be those who
are digging deeply into the faith itself
seeking for God in the midst of our own
questions and articulating them it's
interesting that I was asked to go to
Southern California to be an outside
observer on a youth ministry what really
had happened was that this church a
fairly large Presbyterian Church wanted
to fire their junior high pasture young
woman but they felt like they needed
justification so they need an outside
quote-unquote expert to say yeah she's
terrible you should fire her so it was a
trip to southern california in january
so it seemed a little bit like George
Clooney up in the air but I was ok with
that I could get out of the cold so I
took the trip which probably wasn't the
best idea but I took it and I walked
into their Wednesday night junior high
event and there were about 60 kids there
and I sat in the corner kind of a fly on
the wall and it was pure 100% chaos I
mean it was awful the boys were all in
the back wrestling with each other
literally the boys were trying to run up
the wall they would run as fast as they
could and see how high they get the wall
and then marketing then another word
this is in this isn't before it starts
she's trying to lead worship she's
trying to give announcements and this is
what these boys are doing they're taking
their chairs mean these are good
Southern California boys and they're
trying to surf on the back of their
chairs so they get the back two legs
going and are trying to surf on it and
then they try they start kicking each
other in the head literally like a boy
would stand like this and they would
kick and then it's all dude you're like
this close before your kicker they're
seeing how close they could get this was
happening while she was doing this the
girls were all hot
passing notes and talking and I'm
thinking to myself she's getting fired
like this is bad there no one's
listening to her and it was an awful
awful train wreck until the last five
minutes the last five minutes she
grabbed the mic and she said now we're
going to pray like we pray and oddly all
the kids were silent and then a young
woman raised her hand eighth-grader she
stood up an awkwardly said yeah I guess
I just need prayer because I'm dealing
with it again I had no idea what it was
but clearly the rest of the group did
she sat down an adult leader kind of
touched her shoulder some kids looked at
her another kid raised his hand past
them like that kid prayed for her then
another kid raised his hand said yeah
like some of you probably like no he's
from California like my mom was
diagnosed her cancers back so like I
need prayer for that another kid raised
their hand pray for that kid went on for
about five minutes she grabbed the mic
she prayed for the group and said amen
and the boys literally went back to
trying to kick each other in the head
but it was beautiful they asked me the
next day with you know blood with with
blood on their teeth like should we
should we fires we fire and said no it's
perfect what should we change nothing
it's beautiful here are these kids
actually articulating and sharing each
other's lives and turning to God in the
midst of it wrestling with the goat what
more could we have could she have used
some help on organizing the night she
because she could use them you
communication of course she could but at
the end of the day what matters is to
really wrestle with the depth of these
questions so I want to show you one last
video clip and forgive my overindulgence
but it's TV so we can do one more this
comes from the movie walk the line with
the biopic about Johnny Cash I'm sure
some of you have seen it and this is
early on when Johnny Cash is trying to
get a record deal and as you watch it
you won't need much set up he's going to
kind of audition for this but what I
want you to do is do a little thing for
me is that every time johnny cash or
this record producer that he's talking
to every time that he says song I want
you to replace it in your mind with
whatever you do in ministry whether it's
preach a sermon whether its leader youth
talk whether it's lead youth group
whether it's the Bible study whatever
you do I want you to replace in your
mind
with bible study ease talk sermon and
then we'll talk about it for a second
excuse me sir you the owner of this
place that's me hello I'm jr. cash Sam
Phillips good meet you mr. Phillips I'm
a singer and I got a band we've been
working on some songs women a ton of
Records son it's four dollars well what
about the guys are on the walnut in the
pictures they pay for it off there on my
label how do I get on there the audition
right now call my secretary Marion when
she comes back she's at the salon Jill
says you have an appointment next month
I can't wait that long mr. folks excuse
me I can't wait tell about this one I
can iron it John it's black see what
closer we all have a little black it
looks like you got a funeral maybe I yes
I know when Jesus save me save so very
moment he forgave me he took away my
heavy burdens Lord he gave man peace
with him he say you can't make me doubt
it it's real and I'm gonna shout it I'm
a liar went on I hate to interrupt but
you guys got tough house I'm sorry I
can't market gospel
I don't record material that doesn't
sell mr. cash and gospel like that
doesn't sell those of the gospel of the
way of singing both what's wrong with
listen I don't believe you will
understand me we've come down here we
play for a minute he tells me I'm
believing God you know exactly what I'm
telling you we've already heard that
some a hundred times just like that just
like are you saying we didn't let us
bring it home bring it home alright
let's bring it home he was hit by a
truck nude lying out in that gutter diet
and you had time to sing one song one
song people would remember before your
dirt one song that would let God know
what you felt about your time here on
earth one song that would sum you up you
telling me that's the song you'd say
that same Jimmy Davis tune we hear on
the radio all day bout your peace within
and how it's real how you're going to
shout it or would you sing something
different something real something you
felt because I'm telling you right now
that's the kind of song people want to
hear that's the kind of song that truly
saves people then ain't got nothing to
do with believing in God mr. cash it has
to do with believing in yourself
I gotta cook longer in the Air Force you
got anything in the Air Force you're the
train of coming it's rolling around the
bed and I seen the Sun shines I don't
know when I'm stuck in folsom prison and
time keeps dragging on that train keeps
rolling on down to
when I was just a baby my mama told me
son always be a good boy no never play
with guns but I shot a man in Reno just
to watch him die when i hear that was so
blowing I think my head and cried I bet
there's rich folks eaten in a fancy
dining car they're probably drinking
coffee and smoking big cigars well I
know I had it coming I know I can't be
free
those people keep a-movin and that's
what tortures
powerful powerful scene and I do think
that we have a generation of young
people who are really asking us really
is that really what you're going to tell
me that same old Bible study that same
old youth talk that same old worship
experience are you going to say
something real and I think that becomes
a challenge for us especially gets the
backdrop of this hyper real world where
actually are talks that our practices of
ministry can so easily become just
simulated fodder that just is against
the tapestry of all the other images but
what might it mean to actually
articulate the gospel in a way that
actually saves us that has young people
see us wrestling with the faith that
really actually wrestles with the
experiences of the goat in their own
life and I think that becomes the
challenge for us and I think we have to
think a lot about the practices we do in
our youth ministry we have to think a
lot about how we communicate how we
organize our calendars and things like
that but all of that is secondary to us
actually really wrestling with the faith
ourselves that's really seeking God up
against the goats in our own lives and
the goats in their life so let's pray
and after we pray I think well a few
minutes I know people probably some need
to go but it will have some time for
some Q&A so let me pray for us god I
thank you for these people and I thank
you for the incredible blessing they are
to the church and I thank you for their
depth the depth of courage they have to
seek for you God up against deep
questions in deep fears and young
people's lives we pray today God that we
might ourselves wrestle with the gospel
knowing that if we wrestle with it that
we will find you faithful so give us the
courage to do this gun and bless us with
endurance
thanks for these people